WILL.
FREE SPEECH COUNTS.
IT LIBERALS DELETE ACCOUNTS.
MORE PHYTOLITHS FULLY AS STAIRS
AND DO TWITTER WITH GLEE A BUNC
OF CELEBS SAY THEY'RE LEAVING
TWITTER FOLLOWING MASKS TAKE
OVER.
BEST KNOWN FOR CREATING SHOWS
FOR CAT LADIES.
WHAT DID SHE DO?
'S SWEATS THAT STUPID GREY'S
ANATOMY IT'S BEEN ON FOREVER 17
YEARS I HATE SUCCESS STORIES.
ANYWAY, SHE TWEETED NOT HANGING
AROUND FOR WHATEVER ELON HAS
PLANNED, BUT MY.
GO ALREADY SHE IS DRAGGING THIS
OUT LIKE IT'S THE LAST MEAL ON
DEATH ROW.
OTHERS IN HOLLYWOOD MAY LEAD
TWITTER AS WELL BECAUSE IT 16
YEARS OLD.
OTHERS ARE POSTED TWITTER MIGHT
START CHARGING $20 A MONTH TO
KEEP THE BIT GLORIFIED BLUE
CHECKMARK STATUS AS A PART OF A
OVERHAUL TO TWITTER BLUE THE
SUBSCRIPTION THAT UNLOCKS OTHER
FEATURES THAT LIKE THE OPTION T
EDIT TWEETS THEY CAN ALSO
CONVERT TWEETS FROM, LA HARRIS
INTO ENGLISH.
, LA HARRIS STEPHEN KING TWEETE
A $20 A MONTH TO KEEP MY BLUE
CHECK AT THAT.
THEY SHOULD PAY ME IF THAT GETS
INSTITUTED, I'M GONE LIKE ENRON
THAT'S THE KIND OF TIMELY
REFERENCE THAT MAKES KEEN THE
TOP AUTHOR OF 2003.
AS IF MOSCA, HEALING THE
SCREENSHOT OF ETERNAL MESSAGES
FROM AN EXECUTIVE REGIMEN WHICH
IT COULD BE THE EVIDENCE NEEDED
TO FIRE EXECUTIVES FOR JUST
CAUSE INSTEAD OF PAYING OUT
THEIR GOLDEN PERCHES.
MEANWHILE SOME HIKES ARE
FULL-BLOWN IN DRAMA MODE THIS
GUY LOOKS LIKE HE'S ON THE VERG
OF TEARS LIES IN HERE GO FASTER
THAN THE TRUTH THAT YOU LOVE
MUSKETS TRY TO TAKE DOWN.
>> REALITY CAN'T EXIST ANYMORE
BECAUSE IT CANNOT CATCH UP TO
LIES ON THE INTERNET.
>> I'M NOT A SCHOLAR ON
AUTHORITARIAN HISTORY THIS IS
THE START OF SOMETHING THAT
COULD SPREAD IF YOU ARE GETTING
THE GUARDRAILS OFF THE TRUTH
LITTLE BROTHER WE CANNOT CATCH
UP TO THE LIES ON THE INTERNET
BECAUSE OF HOW THE PIPEWORK
SYSTEM WORKS THE INCENTIVES OF
THE RICHEST PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
THAN THAT'S HOW YOU LOSE YOUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> OKAY JERRY MAGUIRE ELON MUSK
'S TOOK OVER TWITTER FOR A
SECOND AT THAT JFK ASSASSINATED
AGAIN.
>> YOU CONTROL YOURSELF.
WHAT A BABY.
THE GOOD NEWS IS IF LIBERALS
DON'T FEEL SAFE ON TWITTER THEY
CAN GO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WE HEAR TRUTH SOCIAL IS NICE.
WITH THIS.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
IS LIKELY TO TAKE THE BALL AND
GO HOME EXCEPT IT'S NOT THEIR
BALL.
AFTER ALL THESE YEARS OF HAVING
SOMEBODY GO HEY, YOU DON'T LIKE
IT START YOUR OWN PLATFORM WHIL
IT'S EASY TO JUST BUY ONE.
>> IT'S NOBODY UP AND RUNNING
AND ELON MUSK IS FANTASTIC DOIN
THE 20-DOLLAR CHARGE FOR THE
BLUE CHECK.
WE ARE WATCHING THAT DR. SEUSS
BOOK START BELLY--IN REAL TIME
WHENEVER THE BIRDS STARS AND
OTHERS DIDN'T IT'S WONDERFUL.
THE ONLY DOWNSIDE IS I HAVE TO
TRY AND TWITTER.
AS A CONSERVATIVE.
WOULD YOU DON'T HAVE A HUGE
TWITTER FOLLOWING BEING
SUPPRESSED SHADOWED.
AND NOW YOU'RE OUT LIKE UP GOT
UP PUT THOUGHT INTO THIS.
ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE THAT HAS
SHADOW BAND AND PUBLIC WE WILL
TRY AVOID YOU.
LIKE PEOPLE WILL ACTUALLY BLOCK
YOU.
CAT, HOW DO YOU FEEL WOULD YOU
PAY FOR THE TWITTER BLUE THE
VERIFIED?
>> KNOW THAT PEOPLE WITH KNOW I
DID.
THAT'S TRUE IT'S REALLY
EMBARRASSING TO HAVE A BLUE
CHECKMARK KNOW YOU'RE PAYING $2
A MONTH FOR TWITTER THAT'S
EXTREMELY EMBARRASSING ALTHOUGH
I WOULD LIKE I CAN NEVER DO THA
TO MYSELF.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> WOULD YOU?
>> AT THINK SO.
BUT WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
REACTIONS OF OUR?
IT'S OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT AS OF THOUGH TWITTER
BEFORE ELON NEVER CONTRIBUTED T
MISINFORMATION OR DISINFORMATION
.
YOU COULD AT LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT A YOU'RE THAT CONCERNED AN
SAY OKAY I KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
BUT THIS IS MY MORE CONCERNED
OTHERWISE IRONICALLY HE'S BEING
THE ONE DISINGENUOUS AND THE ON
SPREADING THIS INFORMATION BY
ACTING AS THOUGH IT CELLS CAN
HAPPEN NOW WHEN IT WASN'T
HAPPENING BEFORE.
>> I GUESS BEFORE ELON TWITTER
EVERYBODY WAS SO NICE THERE
NOBODY EVER SAID EXACTLY.
AND HOW MANY TIMES OF BEEN ALON
AND TWITTER CRYING I THINK GREG
WILL END UP PLAYING FOR A BLUE
CHECKMARK I DO THINK YOU WILL.
I JUST THINK YOU TRY TO QUIT
TWITTER I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
MISS IT.
>> I'M WONDERING HOW DEMOCRACY
WILL NOT DIE IN DARKNESS WITHOU
THE HOT TAKES OF THE BLUE
CHECKMARK A CROWD I THINK THE
COUNTRIES OVER I THINK IT SHOWS
IT'S ONE PLATFORM WE HAVE ALL
THESE OTHERS YOU CAN'T HAVE ONE
WHERE PEOPLE ARE ALLOWED TO SAY
THINGS THAT MAYBE YOU DISAGREE
WITH.
IT POLLUTES THEIR IDEOLOGY ONCE
AGAIN.
>> THEY NEED TO HAVE EVERYTHING.
WHEN THEY GET TAKEN AWAY IT'S
LIKE JIM GOT PULLED THAT OUT
EVERYTHING FALLS DOWN IT'S
EASIER EITHER THAT OR MAIL
HUSTLER I SAW.
IT COULD BE BOTH.
HIS NAME WAS ITCHING GOTTA HIS
NAME WAS JANKE.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE I'M GOING TO
BE MET PERSONALLY I THINK YOU
SHOULD PAY EVERYONE MORE SO THE
CAN AFFORD THE TWITTER.
LIKE THE SHOW'S BEEN DOING WELL
FOR A WHILE.
I FOR ONE WILL GLADLY PAY TO NO
HAVE TO SUE EVERY SINGLE MONTH
APPLY NEED TO GET THEM ALL THEI
LITTLE APPLICATION NEEDS
EQUITABLY CHECK BECAUSE I GET
IMPERSONATED AT MY MOVIE DOES
AND THAT THE MOVIE ACCOUNT
IMPERSONATORS PIC VERSIONS OF
THE MOVIE UP WHICH IS A PROBLEM.
I NEED THE BLUE CHECKMARK AND
ISN'T THAT WHAT IT'S FOR?
EVERY SINGLE MONTH THEY SAY NO
AND EVERY SINGLE MONTH THAT THE
SAY NO EVEN THOUGH YOU MET ALL
IF IT'S GONNA COST $20 A MONTH
TO STOP IT JUST ONE ROUND OF
CHAOS, I AM FINE.
YOU WANT 20 OR 40 OR 50?
I'LL PAY FOR IT JUST ENOUGH.
>> I AM GOING TO BUY THE BLUE
CHECK NOT FOR ME BUT FOR PEOPLE
I DON'T LIKE.
BE MET BEFORE THEY EVEN NOW AND
MAKE IT LOOK LIKE THEY HAD TO
PAY.
ALEC BALDWIN'S TWITTER HANDLE.
BY HIS SHOULD PROBABLY BUY ONE
NEVERMIND YOU OKAY.
>> I WAS CAN IS A SOMETHING
REALLY DARK THAT WOULDN'T
SURPRISE ME.
>> HILLOCK SKELETON COSTUME ARE
NOW IT'S STILL TOO DARK.
IT'S NOT LATE ENOUGH.
OUT NEXT HE STARTED ON SNL AND